at this Welcome Reception size did
matter Indian leaders made sure that the
US president would be greeted with a
lavish extravaganza and mighty words yes
among this relationship is the most
important partnership of the 21st
century throughout the meeting the tone
between the two leaders was friendly
even loving we're at a point where a
relationship is so special with India it
has never been as good as it is right
now and I think that's because the two
leaders of each country really we feel
very strongly about each other while the
president and the Prime Minister seemed
at ease with each other the outcome of
the talks was meager both expressed
optimism at the prospect of a future
trade deal and left it at that
the meeting was overshadowed by violence
that erupted in another part of Delhi
over a new citizenship law claiming
several casualties those opposed to the
law believe it discriminates against
India's Muslim citizens the timing of
the clashes is an embarrassment for the
Indian Prime Minister eager to show a
polished picture of his nation
protesters also showed up to object to
Trump's visit their message to the u.s.
was clear the Trump's unaffected by the
criticism visited tourist sites between
their official engagements while the
president's will leave India with many
picturesque memories for once the deal
maker has to go home without a trade
deal in his pocket
for the latest from the Indian capital
Delhi let's bring in my colleague Sonia
fall in the car good day to you Sonia
it's been down to business for the last
few days for the two leaders have have
they been getting any closer to
achieving any of their goals that's
right Brian after all that pomp and
pageantry of yesterday it's really down
to business today for moody and Trump
now the start of these meetings you know
Trump President Trump did say that he
was expecting substantial progress in
areas like fighter jets like trade like
energy one area where we are expecting
some progress of courses defense you
know India and the US have really
strengthened their defense cooperation
in recent years and Trump has already
said yesterday that you know they're
expecting to sign a deal worth three
billion dollars which would involve
buying Navy helicopters possibly a
missile defense shield on trade of
course talks are going to be more
complicated and much talked-about mega
trade dealers off the table but you know
we may see in some kind of limited
agreements here which may lead to a more
substantial deal at a later stage the
Sania as we speak we're getting our live
images of the president's a visit of his
talk specifically with some business
leaders how is the president being in in
India being received by the people there
well you know to be honest Brian today a
president on the second day in India and
especially the capital Delhi his his
visit has been eclipsed a bit by some
unprecedented violence and rioting in in
northeast Delhi this happened literally
this broke out hours before Trump landed
in the capital yesterday evening and and
this is this has been reported as a
clash between opponents and supporters
of a very controversial citizenship law
that was passed by the Modi government
last year which critics say you know
discriminates against Muslims and is
undermining the country's secular
traditions but we're seeing very
disturbing images of this violence arson
looting you know markets being set afire
and this is happening literally just 11
miles from where Modi is meeting Trump
so this I think ends up not looking very
good for Prime Minister Modi who was
really praised yesterday my mic
Trump is a great leader and you know
you're also kind of paid tribute to
India's pluralistic democracy son you
fall in the car thanks so much for that
from Delhi